[Musik]
hey leute ganz spontanes video wird
spontan wir haben das glaube ich ganz
gut zwei minuten überlegt das zudrehen
denkt gestern habe ich mit hamza
zusammen spinat nudeln gegessen das auf
instagram gezeigt mein fehler hätte ich
machen dürfen denn das rezept existiert
noch gar nicht auf youtube und ich zeige
euch jetzt wie ich das gemacht das ist
ein ganz schnelles rezept ohne viel
schnickschnack tschäppäts hier meine
fahne dies beschichtet dann gebe ich
jetzt zuallererst tief gespielt das ist
jetzt circa fünf minuten lang schön
weich werden und auftauen
[Musik]
nach fünf minuten ist der spinat richtig
schön weich und jetzt können wir einfach
nur die restlichen zutaten dazugeben die
zeige ich euch jetzt also ich bin
ehrlich gesagt beim mittagessen ist
manchmal fan von fettreduzierter sahne
jetzt habe ich nur die schlagsahne da
war ich backe ja immer total gerne damit
und es gebe ich jetzt da rein
ich verdiene allerdings mit etwas milch
und gleicht sich das so ein bisschen aus
ansonsten könnt ihr auch wenn ihr das
ein bisschen krieger haben möchtet könnt
ihr auch gern so ein bisschen frischkäse
reintun da könnt ihr doppel raum
variante oder die auch wieder die fed
reduzierte variante nehmen und es sieht
so schon ganz anders aus und jetzt
kommen gewürze rhein und an gewürzen
sage ich euch braucht ihr nur drei stück
einmal ist es natürlich salz das ist
ganz klar
dann pfeffer am besten ganz frisch aus
der mühle das schmeckt man immer ein
bisschen besser
die dritte zutat ist curry ich finde
spinat und curry passt so gut zusammen
muss man gucken kurkuma curry und warum
fehlt dir eins kam sah bezirken wir
sozusagen
wenn wir sagen dass man so haben wir
halt den inhalt ausgewertet weil er in
ägypten vor einer woche für eine woche
auch und da hat er sein schwarzkümmelöl
rein getan weil auch im urlaub darauf
nicht verzichten wollte
ja ja genau vor allem kommt das
schwarzkümmelöl aus ägypten ist na ja
auf jeden fall noch ein bisschen körper
rein und fertig leute mehr braucht ihr
nicht und jetzt gebe ich nur noch die
nudeln dazu die habe ich hier natürlich
schon vorgekocht das musste ich euch
nicht zeigen das könnte ja klar das
schaffst du es gebe ich dir einfach hier
mit dazu ich habe übrigens auch ein
bisschen nudelwasser denn die könnten
hier das nudelwasser immer wieder dafür
benutzen um das ein bisschen flüssiger
zu machen oder auch nicht ich schütte
das immer geld erst ganz zum schluss weg
wenn ich ganz sicher bin ich brauche das
nicht mehr
und jetzt ist es schon fertig wie gesagt
aber was mir da immer so ein bisschen
fehlt ist so biss und da hansa und da
nehme ich immer ganz gerne cashewkerne
oder irgendwelche müsse die habe ich
hier schon angeröstet die werde ich
gleich noch ein bisschen fein hacken und
wer aufs ganze gehen möchte und sagt ich
mag das wenn es ein bisschen käse
schmeckt dann nehmt ihr euch einfach
gouda oder wenn ihr möchtet auch ein
bisschen parmesan darüber und gibt das
noch mit in die creme und dann schmilzt
das und wird drehe ich die schön der wie
so eine art käse sahne soße
ja klar
[Musik]
und fertig und jetzt hoffe ich dass er
habe sah das ganz schnell schuldet wenn
wir uns schon richtig hunger und dann
können wir das endlich genießen
ansonsten muss die mikrowelle herhalten
jedoch kommen schwerer
[Musik]